Hi, I'm Eric Boston. Ant-man and the Wasp is full of tiny fascinating details that you might have missed!
I guess the little stuff is what these chapters of the Marvel Cinematic Universe are all about after all.
So, let us rewatch this movie scene by scene and explain all the little Easter eggs and some possible
Clues for Avengers 4 and Blah Blah Blah boring ads and stuff.
This is super boring and no one cares.
Spoiler warning if you haven't seen ant-man in the wasp yet and let's get started this movie opens in a similar way to the first
ant man with a flashback that shows off Marvel Studios impressive De-aging technology
Joining Michael Douglas as a young Hank Pym is Michelle Pfeiffer as young Janet Van Dyne
The original wasp and let's not forget the De-aging on Evangeline Lilly as young hope like crap what a time to be alive
Janet tells her daughter not to worry about missing out on the mission saying that it's so boring
I'll put her to sleep now
Janets mock snooze here could be
Foreshadowing the sort of coma that her character disappears into during her 30-year absence in the quantum realm
The opening sequence also flashes back to the scene from the first ant man showing Hank and Janet's takedown of the rogue
ICBM the moment Janet disappeared in the quantum realm
We also see the clip of Scott's journey into in return from the quantum realm in the first stamp, man
remember there was a missable image of Janet's outline and now this movie digs more into that connection between
Janet and Scott next the movie jumps to the present day
now this actually answers some of the questions we had about when ant-man in the wasp fits in with in the
MCU timeline movie takes place after the events of Captain America Civil War
Because that's the event that Scott is still dealing with the fallout over this movie's events
Take place over roughly three days ending some time before Avengers infinity war
This movie's mid-credits scene ties things in with the end of infinity war with Hank and Janet
Hope fading away from Thanos has snapped presumably it would have taken some time to build a quantum tunnel and Luis's van
But we can probably place his events around mid 2018
Which is roughly present-day Scott and Cassie have built some play tunnels in Scotts house so that they can have adventures while he's on house
Arrest they crawled through a laser field made of yarn which could be a nod to ant-man's comic ant-man second chance, man
And the pretend treasure is this world's greatest grandma trophy
Which is later revealed as Scott's hiding
For the ant-man suit that he's stolen sub war Lewis returns played by Michael Pena who's one of the best parts of this movie notice
How as he prepares for his big business deal he repeats. I'm the boss. I'm the boss. I'm the boss
This is a callback to Civil War when Scott repeated this mantra before becoming giant man the boss
gots ankle tracker being outside the fence triggers the FBI led by Jimmy woo played by Randall Park now Jimmy was a character with a
Long history in the Marvel comics originally a secret agent the 50s searching for the yellow claw a detail that did not age
well
But woo was reintroduced
Later as a SHIELD agent and most recently as a leader of an Xavier type school for young Panem Asian mutants in Mumbai the characters
MCU backstory is that he was a SHIELD agent who was recruited by the FBI
Sidestepping that whole Hydra conspiracy that took over most members of shield that we saw on the TV series when Wu explains to Cassie why?
Her dad is in trouble. He cites these sokovia accords
That was the legislation at the heart of the debate and civil war scott complains that he had to learn magic to
Combat his boredom under house arrest this except this one recurring gag throughout the movie with scott's trickery as ant-man being seen
It's a sleight of hand magic trick. Meanwhile observers seem more impressed by scott's card tricks then his powers as ant-man from here
We see a montage set to the theme for the Partridge Family
Come on, get happy as Scott tries to cheer himself up
We see his electronic drum kit, which could be a nod to Scott and Cassie's drum set in the comic ant-man second chance, man
Also, there's a fun Easter egg here. If you look closely at the online close-up magic University website
One of the course categories is micro. Magic the book that Scott sobs
All reading is The Fault in Our Stars by John Green and later Scott watches this scene from the movie
Animal House one tiny atom in my fingernail could be one little
tiny
uterus, that's of course parallels
This movie's explanation of the quantum realm in which going subatomic opens up its own
Microscopic universe Scott's bathtime dream again flashes back to his trip into the quantum realm in the first movie
And now we see Janet's eyes watching over him establishing the quantum entanglement between the characters this whole hide-and-seek memory
foreshadows the present day seeking among the family members Janet finds hope in the memory and later Hank will find Janet in a
constructed version of their house in the quantum realm Scot
Awakens in hopes van outside the window appears a giant eye of a pigeon really the van is shrunken down
This feels like a nod to Jurassic Park when the t-rex eye appears outside the truck window and later in this movie
We actually hear the line clever girl, which could be another nod to Jurassic park's classic line
God is still in his bathrobe here and he actually spends most of the movie in the bathrobe Paul Rudd joked that this kind of
Parallels the dude in The Big Lebowski. Hope takes Scott to their lab
And if you look closely throughout the lab
you can see that it's being powered by a
Giant Duracell battery can also see pieces of an erector set and clothes pins. The production designers also used blown up LEGO pieces
And paperclips and auto engine coils to give this lab a piece together design the director one two set apart Hank pins
Technology from Tony Stark's super expensive technology. These guys are scrappier
This whole toys used as tech production design also plays into Hank and hopes car collection
Which they keep in a vintage Hot Wheels storage case Hanks shrinks his lab building into a rollaway luggage and they're off to meet with
Sonny birch played by Walton Goggins Sonny birch is a character from the Marvel Comics better known as a corporate. Villain to Tony Stark
He's an associate of Obadiah Stane and he works for Kross technologies
Which was actually the company of Darren cross in the first movie this movie
Version of birch calls quantum technology a gold rush and that he works for some very dangerous people now
it's never revealed who those employers are perhaps we could see a return of Justin Hammer the arms dealer from Iron Man 2 whose
Weaponry has appeared in the Marvel Netflix series or maybe Oscorp Norman
Osborn's weapon technology company with spider-man partly connected to the MCU now one theory is posed that
Oscorp could take over stark tower in Manhattan. Now that Stark has moved Avengers headquarters outside the city
I know you think the dangerous people behind verge could be in the comments below when the deal with birch goes south
Hope takes down. The guys as the wasp finally showing the title hero in action according to Kevin Feige
This was a full-circle moment
Considering the wasp was a legacy character in the Marvel Comics having appeared on the cover of Avengers number 1
this movie's director Peyton Reed explained all the visual effects that went into this sequence the ripple design of the
Shrinking and growing in these movies is called disco trails that look is intended to reflect the art in the comics which tend to convey
Resizing in one panel with a sort of ripple trail the notice these dots what she saw on the trailer of wasp
Dodging and running along the throne kitchen knives now and my breakdown of those trailers earlier this year
I pointed out what wine I should say about how fast this thug would have to throw three kitchen knives at perfect succession like this
well
Check out his arm right after the first throw they had to digitally animate his arm going down to suggest that he would have time
To reach over and grab the next knife
So the effects team actually put fought under the logistics of the stunt and this genius at work withdraws this question
Also notice during the sequence how often the camera cuts to a close-up of attentively Lily
Reacting to the threats in this movie
They designed washes helmet to better reveal the actors eyes and facial expressions to more fully convey the emotions throughout these sequences
They actually shot each action sequence an additional take in a separate close-up setup
They called the array solely for the purpose of capturing these reactions
They also put a lot of thought into the physics of wasps
Gymnastics notice how she skids along the spilled grains of salt the same way an Olympic skater would skid along the ice the animators also
Granulated the flower as it billowed in a cloud behind the wasps the way it would appear in macro photography
The wasps escaped with the tech component is interrupted by the ghost
Now ghost is another character from the Marvel Comics more commonly associated with Ironman
The character here is Avis Starr played by Hannah John Kaman
He may recognize her from season six the Game of Thrones and a few episodes of Black Mirror
Steven Spielberg actually recommended her
personally for this movie after working with her and ready player one Scott Hope and Hank retreat to the office of
ex-con the security company run by Scott Lewis along with our buddies Dave and Kurt with Ti and
David dust mal chin reprising their roles from the first movie ex-con is based on ant-man
Security solutions the security consulting company from the comics and Curt describes ghost as baba-yaga
Which is a supernatural boogeyman
Woman from Reston folklore a version of Baba Yaga actually appeared in the Marvel
Comics at one point though pretty much every character from folklore mythology shows up in some form in these comics Scott
Hope and Hank head over to a university disguised with hats and sunglasses
Scott mocks, the effectiveness of these disguises saying we look like ourselves at a baseball game
This is kind of a meta reference to Steve Rogers and Natasha
Romanov in Captain America Winter Soldier who went incognito and public wearing only hats and glasses
They made up with Hank Pimm's former shield colleague. Dr. Bill Foster played by Laurence Fishburne aka Morpheus from the matrix
You look closely the set designers included a little Easter Egg
Shout out to Lawrence's past movie on the equations on the chalkboard. You listen closely to Foster's lecture. You may have heard him
Say the line the object will be in an out-of-phase in multiple parallel realities in this movie
We learn how the quantum realm can cause phase shifting with molecules
Separating causing objects to split into various phases the idea that objects could exist in multiple parallel realities opens up huge
Implications for the MCU for example if Scott in the quantum realm can phase shift into a separate parallel reality?
That could be one way he could venture out of the quantum realm perhaps in that parallel reality events will have gone down differently
Like different Avengers could have survived. The Annis is stopped altogether. There's a lot to think about here
We'll just have to wait and see in the next Avengers movie how important this seemingly throwaway line into being in Foster's office
he mentions working on a project called Goliath now in the Marvel Comics Bill Foster often teams up with ant-man in the Avengers as
Goliath or black Goliath another part of history that doesn't age too
well
He actually plays a major role in the Civil War
Comic storyline and as appearance now and then see you was teased by a line from Tony Stark all the way back an Iron Man
To tap the Oracle grid and ship stuff out of storage
Everything from projects Pegasus Exodus and Goliath Jimmy woo tracks Scott here
and he's joined by Birch's secret FBI informant
This guy's name is Jeffrey Ballard
Which is actually another name from Marvel Comics
Ballard is a government official who later works with mystique as an enemy to Goliath known as
Centurion Scott having to retrieve the trophy from Cassie's school while his suits resizer is malfunctioning
It's one of the funniest sequences in the MCU
There's actually a little Easter egg on the chalkboard during this and one of the grammar sentences
You can see the phrase ants grow
Of course appearing right behind this ant who's having?
issues with his ability to crow the refractor in the old suit leads them to the lab where it goes sustained revealed to be
Foster's house while sneaking around this place Scott jumps at the sight of ghosts huge suit
Which just turns out to be empty and this is probably where Scott got his inspiration for the later trick on Jimmy one FBI
fooling them with a
giant empty ant-man suit
here Ava and foster reveal her backstory as the daughter of shield scientist Elias star in the Marvel Comics Elias star is the name of
the egghead
which is one of the few villains - ant-man and
He's pretty goofy this movie confirmed the nod by making Ava's father bald though. A little less egg-shaped also in the flashback
We see a young version of Bill Foster though. They didn't need the miraculous de-aging effect here
They've just brought in Fishburne's real life, son
Langston Fishburne to play the role here jumping ahead a little birch puts Lewis and the others under a
truth serum lazy - another hilarious Louie's storytelling montage
I first met Scott even so by Dee and I was like I'm police and he says I'm Scottie and we're gonna be besties tangents
Into is grandma having a jukebox that plays only more see songs
Make sure I get a callback to this later when Louise calls Scott cellphone if you listen closely
It plays the Morrissey song every day is like Sunday
Meanwhile in Hanks lab they hit a breakthrough with a quantum tunnel with Janet taking control of Scott's body
I love Paul Rudd's acting here along with the wordplay
Janet's link with Scott is called an antenna like the antenna of an ant ant
And as they prepare to send Hank down in the quantum realm they plan to track Janet's location using a quantum spectrometer
we've actually heard it's super nerdy device mission before in the first Avengers when Bruce Banner used it to track down the tesseract how many
Spectrometers you have access to all every lab, you know
Tell them to put the spectrometers on the roof and calibrate them for gamma rays back at Scott's house
He chats with his daughter Cassie who wants to be a sidekick actually in the Marvel comics Cassie Lang does follow her dad's footsteps
later becoming the hero stinger also known as stature in the Young Avengers comics rumor has it that they cast a
16 year old actress as Cassie Lang in Avengers 4
implying one that we could see stature in the movie and two the debentures 4 will feature some kind of time jump several years into
the future after the FBI arrests
Hang in Pope Scott breaks them out using ants to cover security camera
Which is actually a call back to the tactic in the first ant-man as they prepare to steal back to lab Louie's shows up in
His van and references that old Budweiser commercial
And after beating ghosts sunny shows up leading to this amazing street chase now staging a car chase throughout the hilly streets of San Francisco
It's an homage to the iconic San Francisco Street chases in the Steve McQueen. Classic Bullitt
The famous lombard street makes a cameo
That's the windy crooked street that tends to show up in a lot of movies set in San Francisco
Including Pixar's inside out and there's just a ton of great sight gags in the sequence including a resized Hello Kitty PEZ dispenser
ant-man using the truck as a push cart and this movie Stan Lee cameo when his car gets wiped out and equips the 60s were
Great, but now I'm paying for it
He's referring to his creation of many of these characters in the 1960s when it was said the whole trippin arts and character designs
Drugs and that now all this crazy cap is being made into
Big-budget movies while all this goes down Hank uses the quantum tunnel and his vessel to explore the quantum realm on his way down
He runs into these tiny creatures now
These are called tardigrades also known as water bears tardigrades are micro animals, but they aren't this small
They're actually only half a millimetre long and kind of visible to the human eye though easier with microscopes
So they're bigger than cells not like these subatomic beings floating in quantum space like this
He eventually finds Janet who doesn't give much of an explanation of how she survived these thirty years
It appears like she turned one of her suits wings into kind of a spear perhaps for hunting her self-defense
Still what the hell did she eat tardigrade meat Janet does tell Hank this cryptic line. This place changes you in ways you can't imagine
Adaptation as part of it, but it's more
evolution now
It seems like Janet is suggesting the quantum realm caused her to evolve giving her a kind of telepathy and healing energy
Maybe she used it to heal her own starvation
But it's interesting that Janet uses the word evolution in the Marvel world
evolution is more commonly used in connection to the x-men who derived their powers from the mutant gene and
Evolutionary trait now in the past the MCU has had to be a lot more careful about using the term mutant or really any
X-men terminology because all those characters and ideas were property of Fox
But now that this merger between Disney and Fox looks like it's going forward
This could be an early step to open the door to mutants in the MCU
Either way Peyton Reed teased that there were some key clues hidden
the quantum realm in this movie to hint at future MCU plot points the way that the wasp was hidden the quantum imagery of the
first amen
They're not gonna be easy to find we may have to wait until the blu-ray comes out to see everything in high-definition
But but but I wasn't able to make this out a moment Hank and Janet sighs out of the quantum realm they passed by something
That looks a lot like some kind of city
the quantum realm is based partially on a micro verse from the Marvel comics which does contain planets and
civilizations that ant-man and other characters like Doctor Doom in the Fantastic Four
Interact with now this place that we see in the shot is some kind of civilization and not just that trick of a lighter
amorphous shapes and colors that could explain how Janet Van Dyne
survives
So long and gives Scott Lang a potential place to go as he waits for his next steps while stranded in the quantum realm meanwhile
Back on the surface ant-man chases Sonny to the ferry now
The very tour guide is a cameo by comedian Tim Heidecker of Tim and Eric
Ant-man and the wasps working title was cherry blue
Which is a reference to a Tim and Eric sketch Scott names the flying ant who carries him ant so Neo
Banderas a callback to the nickname for the other ant that he had ulysses s grant
And as he blows up back the giant man, he gets light-headed and dizzy since being big requires a ton of energy
He also describes the air as chunky at some point now
He's referring to the higher concentration of water vapor in the air which when consumed by bigger gasps at that size
It's harder for his lungs to inhale at all
Cassie watches all this go down on the news where the on screen Chiron labels him as giant, man
Giant man is a character's name when he's giant size because in the comics, it's kind of a separate hero from ant-man
But this year is the first time in the movies
The term giant man is actually listed Janet and Hank returned to the surface Janet heals Ava and Scott
Beats the FBI back home getting his ankle tracker removed and he wonders what it's like on the outside world asking Jimmy
Woo do people still dance now?
This could be a nod to the guardians of the galaxy where star Lord and Drax
Categorized all life forms into ones that dance and ones who don't sadly the beings who danced the Peter quill Groot
Drax all got wiped away and Thanos has snapped
So sure Scott people still dance for like a few more
Seconds and the final scene shows Scott hoping Cassie watching a movie at a drive-in screen
this is another image inspired the ant-man second chance man coming and the movie they're watching is them a
1954 monster movie about nuclear testing at a government
Resulting in giant sized ants terrorizing cities now for all the details in the mid and post credits scenes
We made a couple other videos explaining those Sam broke down what happens in his video and in another video?
We don't speculate on the meaning of Janet Van Dyne bringing up a time vortex and the emotional tone set by that emergency
Broadcast on the TV and how it all connects to Avengers 4 so go watch those videos in the meantime
I'll leave you guys to the question
Would you rather have ant-man get rescued from the quantum realm by the Avengers or Captain Marvel or someone else or should ant-man's?
Experience in the quantum realm be the source of the Avengers end game to fight back against Thanos
Comment down below with your thoughts or tweet me directly idea boss
And as I mentioned before this video was brought to you by Squarespace if you want to set up a super stylish
website fast
You can make it with Squarespace
whether it's to set up a business or showcase some of your creative work or a market to quantum physicists to rescue you from the
quantum realm man
I'm just saying have you considered a sleekly designed website Scott Lang Squarespace released eight new templates this year
That looks so nice and you don't have to know anything about coding or design. They take care of all of that for you
Just go to Squarespace comm for a free trial and when you're ready to launch go to Squarespace
Comm slash new rockstars to get a 10% discount off your first purchase
You can also just click on the link in the description below
reminder to follow new rockstars on Twitter for updates on our videos like this video share it around and subscribe to new rockstar as for
All of our marvel deep dives theories and updates. Thanks for watching. I got the rest of the candy bar to eat. Bye